so effectively every week the government
says these are all the things that
American citizens can't do for about the
next 20 years I am Nick Gillespie for
Reason TV and today we're talking with
Derek Khanna he's a lawyer and an
intellectual property specialists who
has great paper out from Lincoln labs
called how to fix patents economic
Liberty requires patent reform Derek
thanks for joining me okay talk about a
patent define it for us what does it do
and what did the founders who put patent
law in the Constitution of the idea what
did they want out of it so a patent is a
government-granted monopoly and it's
legally defined as the right to exclude
so the government gives you this
monopoly and says only you can do this
invention and no one else can so
effectively every week the government
says these are all the things that
American citizens can't do for about the
next 20 years and they were really
supposed to be kept for inventions
things that required a tremendous amount
of research and development to allow you
to recoup upon that investment and also
had a second reason which is they wanted
people to come forward and to share
their discoveries in the form of a
public disclosure so others could learn
from it I don't pose to keeping it as a
trade secret and keeping it internal so
this is the difference between a trade
secret or something like the coca-cola
formula which is hidden in a vault
somewhere in Atlanta we believe in a
patent it's like the electric light bulb
the Edison light bulb where you actually
write down everything so people can see
from it yes yeah and and a patent term
lasts for about 20 years so talk about
the abuse of the patent the patent
process right now where is it the most
absurd so in the founding era patents
were reserved for things they were
really novel they're about 600 of them
granted the first 10 years required the
Secretary of State to personally sign
off and the reason was is because they
didn't consider this to be part of the
free market they saw this as an
improvement upon the free market and you
really wanted to be careful but when you
actually did this but today they're
being granted across the board and
they're being granted in some cases for
technologists moving so quickly that by
the time the patent expires there's
almost no purpose
to it anymore what's an example of that
so in window in 1995 you know Microsoft
got a whole bunch of patents for you
know their upcoming operating system
Windows 95 well was there a big party of
January this year when you had hundreds
of patents expiring and programmers able
to create their own versions of Windows
95 it's just an illogical premise in the
modern age yeah and you talk about I
mean one of the examples in the paper
you have an illustration from the
successful application for a patent on
exercising a cat with a laser pointer
yes I wanted to be on your show today to
admit that I have violated this path you
know Isis but all of us with cats or
laser pointers have done this so that I
mean this is clearly something has gone
well off the rails when that happens now
other patents or or at least the
processes that they that are patented
are useful after the patent expires so
talk a little bit about that in the
context of pharmaceuticals because this
is a place where drug makers make a very
strong case that they need that monopoly
on profits on revenue in order to pay
for or incentivize them to bring new new
drugs to market so our report is in
favor of patents but I want to go back
to kind of constitutional principles
reserving them for when it's really
necessary and pharmaceuticals are a
pretty strong argument for when they are
necessary and the reason is because it
costs several hundred million or up to a
billion dollars to bring a product to
market to pharmaceutical a long time to
get it through FDA testing and there's a
lot of things that can be done there
along the way but if it cost about a
billion dollars to get the drug to
market you know the economic data seems
to indicate that if they didn't have a
period to recoup that investment through
something like a patent then they may
not do so
so pharmaceuticals are a very good
example of where patents are in my
opinion rightfully granted not the least
of which because I'm not going to
accidentally violate somebody's patents
I can actually look up in a directory
and say hey this actual formula has
already been patented so we all know
people talk a lot about patent trolls
you know particularly in software
situations how does that affect and what
what has happened in recently to kind of
rein in patent trolls a little bit but
clearly not enough so patent trolls are
effectively where you have a person or
an entity and they they usually are
sitting on several legitimate patents or
a bunch of them and they go out in the
market and they find a startup or
usually it's a smaller company that's
doing something that they consider to be
a little bit similar and then they
usually send them a demand letter
knowing that it will cost about four
million dollars to bring their product
to market and so they asked for you know
$50,000 so they're asking for an amount
of money substantially cheaper than
bringing their product to market and
they're able to use usually these very
low-quality patents that should never
have been granted to begin with to shake
down these companies when they usually
had no intention of actually bringing
that patent to market so talk a little
bit though about you know you talk about
pharmaceuticals and it's like yeah if it
cost you a billion dollars to bring a
market drug to market you're gonna want
to you you're gonna want some assurance
to get investors to say don't worry
we're gonna have you know we're gonna
get all the money generated by this for
twenty years or the rest of the term but
then there are also industries where
there are no intellectual property
guarantees at all that are very
innovative what are some of those and
what's going on with oh sure
so you look at the fashion industry
which is just thriving in the United
States and we've chosen the United
States to not allow for any form of
intellectual property protection and
when the fashion industry cried to
create their own cartel to create a de
facto IP protection that was struck down
by the US Supreme Court but in France
and other countries I have a rich
history of fashion right they've gone
the other way and actually you've seen a
lot of that you know shift to the United
States and so we have a thriving fashion
sector without IP and something in I
mean I guess cuisine or menus sure that
happens all the time it's same with you
know you know football plays you know
whatever the football team comes up with
a new play other football teams you know
copy it and in database database
protections another example which is in
the United States a database can't
receive a patent protection or a
copyright protection but in Europe they
can and what's actually happened is the
database market is actually shifted to
the United States there's a you know in
copyright it's probably because the in
copyright the term of the copyright
keeps getting extended whenever Mickey
Mouse is about to go in the public
domain or a couple of other major kind
of entertainment powers can like muscle
Congress to do their bidding it has that
same type of thing been happening in
patent or is a
it hasn't been more constrained and if
so why it's a good question and patent
started off at 14 years just like
copyright whereas copyright has gone to
130 135 years patents has only gone to
20 years so it's stayed relatively
similar to you know the prescriptions of
the founding era except for what is
being granted for the founding era would
only be granted for inventions they
would have never believed that you could
patent design right or or a business
practice that yeah so we should
particularly pernicious if you think
about it because that's how the free
market really operates is you know
McDonald's has the idea of coming up
with a fast-food burger joint and then
Wendy's comes along and all these other
companies and that's what competition is
do we get rid of do we throw out
hundreds of thousands of useless patents
or do we just stopped issuing dumb new
patents or what talk a little bit about
what has to happen in the reform process
so there you know the 90s they're giving
out patents like crazy for software and
then they started to kind of rein that
back in realizing that this is really
bad in the software context because
often times there's only one way to do
something in the software world and so
that started to be corrected by the
courts but there's a lot more work to be
done but the good news is that you know
these things expire so if Congress acts
today a lot of these kind of bad patents
already in the books begin to expire
relatively quickly what are what are
your your basic reforms so one would be
kind of you know really changing the the
ease with which patents get issued what
are the other necessary reforms yeah I
mean first of all you want these things
to be granted quickly er which is that
if we want patents
you probably want patents that come to
you and quicker than two years you can't
wait two years to find out if you have a
patent or not but the second one is it
used to be that you had to really teach
the world what your invention was but
today I've never met an engineer in my
life who says you know when I want to
learn how to do this I look up the
patent filing they're deliberately
written to be opaque so they're I mean
you're saying in the 19th century and
when you're talking about an invention
you could go look at you know the cotton
gins patent thing and you could figure
out how to build it from that yes yeah
and so that's actually in the law
already right the law says that it has
to be you know readable and explanatory
all we have to do is enforce that law
but if they need to be strengthened by
Congress because they're not following
right
this goes to your earlier point about
patents and copyrights are
government-granted monopolies or
government granted rights and they're
not natural rights that you know come to
us from God or the Creator but rather
the idea is that they advance what is it
the practical and useful arts or
whatever I mean that they progress the
sciences yes lawyers yes so that you
know they should be useful in some way
as opposed to a way of dodging people
figuring out how you're doing your
business exactly and one interesting
thing is when the founders were
considering this this language in the
Constitution
Madison actually had a whole host of
other things he wanted to add and he
thought also could lead to the promotion
of the sciences and useful arts things
like allowing for universities or in in
that was the context that they were
talking about it was just so important
that this instrument of regulatory power
had to push science forward you're
talking about this in the context of
economic Liberty because things like
copyright certainly patent is a
restriction on economic Liberty so
there's a cost benefit the government is
supposed to be making to say okay yeah
the cost here to economic Liberty will
be outweighed by the benefits how do you
how do you or how does Lincoln labs kind
of conceive that economic Liberty as a
fundamental right or a fundamental
aspect of the American experience
sure so I actually believe economic
Liberty is a natural right I don't think
that copyrights or patents are but the
founders are very clear if you have an
idea or a business you should be able to
bring that to market and you're not
guaranteed success but you're gonna
succeed or fail on the merits of how
that performs in the marketplace and so
so the default is that we should have
maximum economic Liberty and then the
government or whatever authority really
has to make a very strong case to say
except in this area in this small narrow
and that's what the founders intended
both in the you know the privileges and
immunities Clause and the privileges or
immunities clause there are several
provisions of the Constitution where the
founders really try to protect this
right do you find that the kind of
Appeal or I mean I I think it really
flushes out the context of why we have
IP and whatnot but the appeals to the
founders or the you know does that
resonate with people in contemporary
business settings or are they kind of
like look you know that's you know that
what the Constitution is like over
twenty year
sold you know it's like in a totally
different world well I think it should
resonate with them because we're talking
about here is really basic free-market
principles and the interesting thing
about you know the regulation stuff is
you know conservatives and libertarians
often have a lot of trouble with this
mounting level of regulation but at
least with regulations the agency's
proposed to look at pros and cons we may
disagree with their conclusions but what
we see is that the you know patents
being granted are 10 20 30 times more
page length than the regulations and
there's no pro and cons being waived and
they're being given out every single
year kind of willy-nilly and it's really
the regulatory state run them up we're
in an age now which I think is one of
the benefits of the financial crisis is
that there's a really kind of
transportus an interest in crony
capitalism and rooting it out and this
you make a strong case in the in the
paper that you know it is big companies
powerful companies are often trolls
their cronies explain how that works
well basically what I want is I want to
market where you know there are very low
barriers to entry for new market
participants because I believe that's
where innovation comes from Joseph
Schumpeter has this whole theory called
creative destruction which is new guys
come in and old guys either adapt or die
and oftentimes you have a lot of these
incumbents that really patent obvious
things that stifle that process I'll
give you an example let's say you and I
decide to go into business my idea is a
cell phone that uses Wi-Fi to keep
recharging the battery now this is
technically possible and so it would be
a cell phone that never turns off and so
you know we're working on this idea I'm
about to we're about to bring it to
market launch a Kickstarter Austin you
give me a call and he said hey that cell
phone we were working on it has rounded
rectangles doesn't it well Apple has a
patent on that we're gonna get sued I
say oh this is ridiculous okay so we
scrap that plan let's go back to the
drawing board
let's look up how many patents apply a
smartphone so that way we really don't
infringe anybody's patent and you call
me up and you say well it's about 300 to
400 thousand patents that apply to
smartphones I say well how much does a
patent lawyer cost that gives you an
example of what it's like for an
innovator today that's one reason why we
haven't had you know new startups
offering new smartphones in the market
and we want most markets to
such that anybody can bring an idea like
that they're not guaranteed to succeed
but they lose because the consumer
doesn't like their product not because
you know all this thicket of patents and
patents or you can buy and sell them so
if you're a big company you can buy up a
lot of patents and hang on to them and
then kind of trot them out when you
think you might be able to use that to
crush competition and with the
smartphone market in particular actually
what we're seeing is you have Samsung
and Apple and a few other companies and
they're basically all infringing on each
other's patents and they have this you
know noncom you chew assured destruction
policy I won't see you if you don't sue
me for the most part until it goes so
it's a cartel effectively among a few
producers who the one thing that they
all agree on is to keep out little guys
who might actually come up with
something truly innovative and transform
yes and that's the worst of all worlds
is that you know that may work for Apple
and it may work for Samsung but if you
and I have this new idea for a cell
phone you know Apple is probably not
gonna license it to us unless they don't
think we're a threat and that's you mean
you know you don't want to have to ask
permission from the incumbent in order
to innovate right well we will leave it
there the the paper is how to fix
patents economic Liberty requires patent
reform the author is Derek Khanna it's
out from Lincoln labs Derek thanks for
talking to us examine for reason TV I'm
Nick Gillespie